all right wendy wendy where'd you grow
where were you from originally
i was born in anaheim california and
tell me about your family you had both
your parents
um no i don't know my grandfather never
met the student in the picture
i stayed with my mom named my two
sisters and born apart
and uh how was your childhood huh how
was your childhood
not good i got childhoods and uh
i was only one and uh
i got taken away at school you know
and uh my sister got chickened away two
weeks later
what kind of stuff was going on huh what
kind of stuff was going on
um my mom was mentally [ __ ] she got
hit by a truck on her fifth birthday and
the damage to friends so she had a mind
like a kid
you know so but i don't know why
i understand why she need me all the
time and
not damn it i don't know if it's a trip
i guess because i look like my father i
guess i don't know
yeah and i got taken away
i went to mclaren hall from there and i
went to different places
you know never stayed in one long enough
to go to school
you know i was a climate runaway and i
came over here to just south central l.a
and i met this black man i had this bath
and i said can i come and live with you
said sure honey i was on sports the next
day with two favorite bags
from the age of 13 until he passed away
three years ago and um took care of me
but i experienced figaro street
you know wanted to see what was sold so
he was a boyfriend or a pimp or
no i've experienced pimp yeah but i
think
i need none of my money that i can't do
it and he's never saying
how many no man tell me basically i
don't give my money
[ __ ] i need you to bring me this and i
don't need that [ __ ]
you know i've been out by all my life
and where i live at now all the kids all
the youngsters
they respect me to the fullest call me
mom's apology you know
i've been kidnapped i've been stabbed
pushing a walker down the street making
my own money so you're
you've been working figaro for how many
years huh you've been working figaro for
how much i've been working for
from the age of 14 to now and how old do
you say i'll be 55 on the 26th of july
you know i i had a rough life and you're
still doing it
um yeah to pay for my own room you know
not young no more so they don't pick me
up like you know because i used to make
money when i was young
but now i'm older so they want the young
booty
you know but i do have my regulars and i
do have friends that just come by and
cost me money you know but it ain't for
me no more you know
it ain't it's just getting too dangerous
and everything
so i don't experience no more death
situations or anything no more in my
life
what kind of stuff have you seen have i
seen
yeah seen so much out there so much
killings
young girls not even 16 or
some of them are not even metal out
there on the street
and that's you know stop and i talked to
them i said well they call me mom's
auntie out here you know and they're so
beautiful
so beautiful girls you know they could
do something better with their life
instead of this
and i've been looking for is love
they're searching for something they're
not getting at home
my mother figure father took us
something and that's why they come to
the streets
you know they bump into them dudes and
[ __ ] you know
thinking that you know that
they're just using you but uh don't wake
up when some
tragedy happens or whatever you know my
amber that's my girl
there ain't nothing i won't do for her
because when i was sick
she took care of me paid my rent
and i love her i'll take my shirt off
i'll die for her because
she's a good person you know but
people take advantage of stuff all the
time but
that's my heart you know what i'm saying
and uh
i respect you to the fullest yeah i just
right now i'm going through some changes
right now so my birthday's coming up i'm
gonna see my twin sister ain't seen
since i'm
2007. you don't know
and that's all i want god to do is let
me see her and i'm fine and i
have bone cancer right now oh you do and
um
you know it's without bone marrow
it's i'm not going to be able to survive
too long you know what i'm saying
and they're not going to try to help
find me none or anything because
you know it's all about the money but
god has let me live you know
and i really don't know why i wasn't
even born
because this has been my whole life and
i feel like i'm
being punished for the sins of my
ancestors or something because
i ain't the number got taken away from
drivers and that was it
you know and this is what that
came upon me so you know
but i'm very discreet um i'm humble
and i have a lot of love in my heart for
people even though they do me wrong
i still have love because it's within me
you know
i get mad don't get me wrong but
you know fingers disease in my mind
and karma's a [ __ ] i'm still
paying for karma i did back in my day
do you have children i have three girls
and did you raise them
um i see one every day the other one
in kansas most one her brother got
killed out here
he's only out here for two weeks and
that's the first time i've seen him
since i had him
and her but she didn't come but she has
resentment or
you know it's gonna take a decade to
build that bond with her because they
only knew me as the aunt
they didn't know i was their mom until
my grandmother opened her mouth
and you know that i sent them money on
you know holidays
you know when i called i said let me
speak in my daughter
and she get on the phone and say hi
david how you doing you need something
she said no i got everything i need
right now thank you she said i'm gonna
put you on the phone with aunt tony
and that's it she don't really talk to
me too much i can understand that
but she don't know why i had to give
them
up i'd rather give them to my aunt in
the state
take over you know but i have another
dollar next summer she lives in
california city
and my youngest one she's a high name
this baby the keeper
yeah do you uh are drugs a part of your
life
um i do drugs uh
occasionally but i don't do them like i
used to because i know
i have that i can't you know and i don't
need nothing that's going to make me
sicker and stuff and i don't really have
to play state right now
so um it's hard for me
i'll be trying to pay rent but they want
eighty dollars for a [ __ ]
three bag motel and they worked it to me
you know i'm saying
but
if i had to i'd i'd have to get one but
i'm gonna make romney streets like all
night all day
you know it's too much [ __ ] out there
and drugs are killing [ __ ] off
you know it's all about drugs and what
they can get from you
you know and that's it they don't really
be concerned about the person
it's all about them but have you been
loved before huh have you been in love
before um i think i've been in love
i could really say yeah my kids father
i didn't have feelings for none of them
except this one guy
on 109th and broadway i don't know what
it was but
it was a month before he even got
intimate but when we did
oh my god he woke me up he brought up
the uh you know
brought out me you know and that's been
a long time since i felt like that with
a man you know what i'm saying
he just did things that i would not been
knowing a man do i
think nasty her you know something like
that
but he used to beat me all the time he
used to jump on me and that's the only
problem we had
i stayed with 12 years and uh i can't
count on both hands how many times we
have sex
but um he started [ __ ] around another
woman i come home catching
but [ __ ] making [ __ ] you know i care
about what you do
but you can respect me and then [ __ ]
are too you know
but um yeah i felt real hard for him
because he made me feel alive again you
know sexually
and it was awesome you know i felt hard
for him
and i didn't feel like that with my kids
father and i
that was my i feel like that was my
first love really
to tell the truth because i never had
feelings like that from no man
on him was that was that the best point
of your life
uh he he was a friend i met that big
became friends but
he left and got his own apartment now
and works
but he only comes over there to see me
you know
what what was the best point of your
life what do you mean
what was the best where were you
happiest in your life
let me tell you i never really felt
happy
in my life you know i'm really happy
that's a shame i'm a big kid right now i
want to do fun things you know
go places that i ain't never been before
i never had a birthday party
in my life and she's going to make it
happen too
my girl yeah i'm gonna have a little
birthday i want to take with party hats
and
things you blow out and i don't care who
else don't come
you don't have to bring me no gifts i
just want
my a real friend around me and there's
only two girls that i know are my real
friends
quick fire and her anybody that says
look at the hospital with me
to see if their bone marrow will match
mine that's a friend
that's the friend and i know she's my
friend you know
you know really she just stresses out
too much and
and i don't know what she told you about
this dude that's
you know anthony whoever he is but she
really cares about this man but
you don't give a [ __ ] and she got beat
up
by dude he's here i thought i was just
admitting when i seen the face
that [ __ ] oh i had raised him you
know i wish i wouldn't know who this
dude was
i swear and i all he said was
it comes along with the territory
yeah i'll be trying to watch out for her
you know as best as i can
you know because she's young and
beautiful
she's confused also you know confusion
you know really you don't know what real
love is because
that's not real but i've been through
abuse
with all my men except my youngest
daughter's daddy
that stays on the hunter agency abusive
and until you stop that abuse the cycle
is going to keep continuing
continuing she is a beautiful girl
and she's got a good heart but she lets
people misuse it
you know that's so much anger yeah what
do you think the cause is of
of the self-destructive lifestyle that
these women that work figaroa
have you think it's the childhood do you
think that you've been it's your
childhood it's something i'm not getting
at home that's why
i used to run away looking at searching
for love
and i'm still searching in a way and you
know like i gotta have love i want
somebody to love me
for who i am for wendy not because of
where i look
or whatever you know i've tried so hard
for preparation natural minds to get
these wrinkles to [ __ ] beyond
and so many things i want to do
but people don't have the time to help
nobody know
you know so i just
give it to god and let him handle
everything i'm still
i still doubt him because of lifestyle
you know you know i've been praying and
crying out for help to him
but she might but in his time
he'll help me whenever but i got to make
them steps first
you know i got to take a step before he
takes two
if i'm not doing it and i'm not trying
to help myself
why is anybody else going to try to help
i got to be the one to do it
you know and i thank god to this day
and of all the [ __ ] i've been doing when
i got kidnapped oh my god
he cut all my hair off and shaved my
ball ahead
tied me up i had a cast on each arm
the tube of my stomach my ribs are still
like that and i bought six pounds of
blood and i had 170 stitches in my head
he [ __ ] me up and i didn't see him in
pictures until i went to court and when
i seen me
look at my back on the beat oh my god i
just
you know he's out of prison now
i see him every day his name is double
numbers godfather
and you know he says he didn't do that
he didn't do this they did
i know what happened but he took me to
the hospital and i said who did this to
you and i said
i brought me here and the [ __ ] i
didn't say none i don't know
uh but one of them got her mom worked
out the police station so
she made him testify on my behalf he
gives him
but he's out you know and
he he wants he tries to say hi stuff
i'll say hi and stuff
and but there's nothing you have to talk
about you know
nothing we got to say you know and she's
saying
the only reason why i didn't kill you
when you got um when when i got out is
because you stopped him from beating me
up on the court but
never beat him up so bad i couldn't take
anymore i said
i said stop that's enough you know and
what he did to me
i couldn't let them continue but that's
not my heart
you know you know it's not within me
you know he did his time and whatever i
don't hold grudges or whatever i just
move on with my life i don't think about
it
i got so much i bury so deep that i
don't let it come to surface
and when i feel like it's coming to
surface i get away from everything all
the negativity and just
be by myself you know uh states you know
because
i don't want to be going off and it goes
and i grow up on the wrong person and
[ __ ] because that
i hope i'm not boring you am i no
yeah so i believe it was life
i'll be 55 on the 26th of july
and uh i'm leaving
this area is it was it a difficult
transition to go for like when you were
younger in your 20s or whatever 30s you
were
probably in demand and made a lot more
money oh i made it kill it everybody
tells me that
they said when you were to find this
white [ __ ] out here
you had [ __ ] circling corners
damn they're reckoning to get your ass
and uh you know what though and you were
fine [ __ ] you were beautiful
but you know what i never took the time
to even see that
you know and when i hear them tell me
that it's a trip because i never thought
about myself
you know about nothing like that you
know
and most of the time every man i had
i had they were all getting back
retaliated
the only one that wasn't hard hard was
my youngest daughter's daddy
all he did was sell dope and [ __ ] and
whatever
but the other one had one of my twins by
the first time
and i was with him he swear up and down
i was sucking some man's dick on the
freeway chased me all my
you know i said go there i pulled up in
my mind
i pulled in my mom's yard and she kept
hearing this noise
man i just want my girl out of the car
because just just remember i'm not going
to drive you i'm not going to do nothing
i just want my woman up out of the car
he said get out get out
i said no take off he's going to kill us
like that and
i got out and uh he grabbed me said why
wouldn't he why do you want to do me
like this
he said take him by my father's house
i'm killing this [ __ ]
you know and he's too possessive you
know if the man said hi
he'll say oh would you do you [ __ ] her
before or what you know he
tripped like that you know that's how he
was and he should be
jump on me and [ __ ] all the time too
yeah
and i heard the trip yeah
but i had to get a couple of good new
friends
you know you've had a live stream your
life has been a string of
abusive relationships it sounds like no
nothing i mean
your mom i thought that relationship but
they weren't
you know and now
you know i just dig in and deal with the
[ __ ]
yeah right now i ain't had a man in my
life for so long
i really don't care you know i'm just
trying to focus on myself and get my
life
together because before i want to be
right with myself in him you know
and i refuse to down the street my
family
the prejudice they're full brother
italian sicilian
they are prejudiced and uh
only person that's not is my aunt tony
and kansas
you know i'm calling her up and saying
antonio's like a dick your [ __ ] ass
to get to your front door
she says oh honey i love you don't do
that
she said honey have you ever smoked uh
crap i said you're not gonna be mad at
me if i tell you truth no
she said no i said yes i have you know
and uh i could talk to her and
she'll discriminate or anything against
me you know
and uh the rest of them
you know ain't no good
you know i didn't have to live my life
like this
somebody could take me in from the
family they took my twin sister in
and my sister sam so what's up with me
that's why i feel like i'm being
punished for the third generation
i really do because you know my fam
they're not rich but they're well off
just put it like that
and uh yeah
that's awesome all right well thank you
so much for sharing your story
you're welcome very interesting i
gave you the whole truth though about my
life
you know it's more but it's okay and i
thank you for meeting you and it's a
pleasure
and god bless all right thank you yeah
i just want to get back and give me some
rest
you